Where would science be without the occasional accidental discovery?
Hey guys, I'm Patrick Jones for Buzz 60.
Especially when it comes to medicine.
Penicillin was discovered when Sir Alexander Fleming left his experiments for a two-week vacation...
...only to come back and find that a Petri dish culture of bacteria...
...was contaminated with a fungus that was killing it.
He decided to call it mold juice,...
...but a few months later decided to get all sciency and call it penicillin.
Viagra was accidentally found when looking for a high blood pressure cure.
Now it facilitates the opposite.
The microwave was stumbled upon...
...when a magnetron inspector felt a candy bar all of a sudden melt in his pocket.
Alfred Nobel, yes, the Nobel Prize Nobel, discovered dynamite the hard way...
...after several experiments in tending to learn how best to store explosives went wrong.
One attempt even ended in fatalities including Nobel's brother.
Nobel figured out the idea behind dynamite...
...after nitroglycerin powder leaked onto some damp sediment.
Meaning the Nobel Prize is named after a guy who despite several accidents...
...still had explosive powder leaking.
Buzz 60 now you know, pass it on.